please welcome this year's gold medal
award winner narrative film making Luke
Matheny Wow okay here we go so uh I
really need to thank the academy I think
everyone who knows me knows that I'm a
academy nut when I was 13 I memorized
every single best picture that's been my
annoying party trick ever since so you
can test me afterwards so this means a
lot for me to actually be thanking the
Academy and I just have to really thank
them for how much generosity they've
shown the other filmmakers who all been
amazing to meet and to see their films
you know we've uniformly that they took
us to see the writers and directors and
the cinematographers and all sorts of
people the governor's dinner and you
know uniformly everyone has just been so
generous and thoughtful and candid and
helpful so I think and it you know
didn't driving us around everywhere they
give us free food everywhere we go so I
think I'm getting very skewed picture of
LA but if it were always like this this
would be the best city in the history of
the world so so just thank you so much
to the Academy for that alright people I
need to thank first of all my brilliant
cinematographer and wonderful
collaborator Bobby Webster who came out
like just invaluable to the whole
process all my great professors back get
a new york and nyu kimmel was classmate
of mine and a great friend so this is a
big night for us better luck next to
your columbia and
that was petty I'm sorry um I can do
thank Levi a braai know who was my
script supervisor and my editor but also
the guy looking at the monitor during
all the scenes that I was in so he's the
person he was like the vice president so
if I had died he would have been the
director so I really really relied on
him my amazing producing team at GG de
menthe Stephanie wamsley Ryan Silbert
first assistant director Nick Ordway
sound designer sarees sound Rob Meyer
and Ian Harding and robbed for Axl
inscript advice my actors I need to
thank marion brock Chris Hirsch emily
Young Miguel Rosales Amanda hellas la
peau melt see Lydia sudol Ryan Colin
Casey Smith Becky Lasky a couple
organizations were very generous with
post-production money that relief was a
load off for me it's Warner Brothers
American life TV wafer entertainment and
national board of review let's see I
citibank for administering my ample
student loans and my mother for
additional financial support and for
driving up from Florida to do the craft
services which was amazing the jewel of
the craft service table was actually a
couple of hand-rolled cigarettes for the
grip and electric team so that was
really as she was well-loved on set so
my friend Susie from high school or
drove in from Vegas today to be here
Steve my good friend here Harry and
Cindy and then I guess finally my
amazing composer and the love of my life
Sasha Gordon thank you so much